27歳の男性からコメントが来てたんで
それに答えていただいてもいいです
かこんばんはまず初めに私は戸塚さんの
言動を興味で追っております理解できる
ところもあればしねるところどちらもあり
ますと言いますが私は27歳派遣社員で
借金も少々ありろでもない人間です正直
生きてる価値はとかさんからしたらないと
思うでしょうし私自身もないと思っており
ますここで質問です私は努力ができません
何かアドバイスしていただけませんか全て
に対して無気力で
楽なことばかりしかできませんこれは幼児
教育のミス幼児期にそういうことが努力
できるように何でもこう向かっていける
ようにね逃げたらおしまいだから向かって
いかんと進歩しないからねそういう教育を
することができるまた残念ながら幼児しか
できないねからそいつを過ぎちまって今の
幼稚園や保育園みたいにただただ甘やかし
てまたで来るんでそっとしておくという
そういうことをやってたら時をする
リベラルの言うことを聞かにゃ良かったん
やだけどおそらくリベラルに反対すること
なんて誰もできなかったんやね少しは
リベラルに責任を押し付けてマスコミに
損害賠償を請求したらええねこの人は
マスコミにとうしかないマスコミ
つっかかっていって少し稼いだらどうかな
1人では無理かもしれんけどそんな大勢
おるんだからみんな集めて引きこもりも
集めてみんなマスコミのせいだと言って上
を出してみさすがの裁判所もな考えるから
今後の人生どうやって生きていけばいい
ですかね27歳でできるだけのことをし
ながら生きてくるしんないよねともかく
独立せんことにはダメなんだから金を稼ぐ
方法余裕ができたら嫁さんをもらう嫁さん
もらったら子供を作るその子供のために
だったら一生懸命できるからそこまでまず
持っていったらどうやろうね今からは
しっかり就職して仕事をしてお金を稼いで
家庭を持つっていうのがベストですかね
そういう並のことがまずいかんと人波の
こともできんのに人波以上のことができる
わけない27歳で要求されることもう
おそらく普通だと結婚しとるわな結婚する
ためには就職せないいかんよね就職でき
たら家も欲しいというないもねだりになっ
ちまうけどまずは就職少しでもたくさん
兼ねためる結婚子供そこまで行ったら後は
もうおか見えてくるや男はな女子供のため
に生きとるんだよ
全てに対して無気力になってしまって努力
が難しいとか自分を理するのが難しいって
いう人から結構コメントが来ててえ手遅れ
ないよねからそういうものがちゃんと
できるようになるのが幼児教育なそこを
リベラルのおかげでねちゃんとやろうと
すると奴らがよくやれを入れてきて虐待だ
と言い出すわけやうちにだってねあの子供
がやっぱり怖いもんで泣いたりするわけよ
海の上でさとリベラルが来るでてめえの
ことやっとれでいたなってくるよねなんで
人に干渉するんやおせか焼きリベラルはね
あれはね自分たちが正しい自分たちが偉い
と思っとるもんで人におせか焼くんだ
手遅れになってしまった人はしいて言う
なら何をすればいいみたいなあったりし
ますかほら頑張れんだけど頑張れんのやろ
頑張れん人間に頑張れて言ったってほらは
無理やあれはね本能なんよねだから本能の
トレーニングをしとかないかんやったで
本能が完璧にトレーニングされた状地上意
の3つがあるからね本能もその状態を公然
の木って言うんだだから公然の木を養う
ためには幼児教育からやっていか
ねや手遅れになった人なりに本能を高める
方法とか本能を高める方法はもうおそらく
もうないと思うだから今まで作った本能
そいつを最高に出すということはできる
やろ正しいことばっかりしてれば自然に
本能が強くなるよとただし今まで培った
以上には強くならんやろうね理性で持って
100%ポテンシャルを発揮するにはどう
すればいい理性は役に立たないからもう
生ぜ正しい行動かどうかの判断をすること
やな正しい行動をした後は必ず満足感が
あるんだから満足感が出たらあちゃんと
正しい行動したよという証拠になるけど
そういう人ほとんど満足感ないやろね何
やったってもう1つやもう1つ言っとるわ
な結論幼少期が大事っっていう幼少期が
一番大事なみつ子の魂100やろからその
時にちゃんとやっとかないかんのにその時
に甘やかすからいかん
ね以前大人になってからこ自分を高める
方法としてマリーンスポーツとか格闘技と
か死に直面する場面を作るといなことを
おっしゃってたと思うんですけどそれもう
1回伺ってもいいんですか生きる力が大事
ね本の中で1番基本的な本能これがね生命
力なんよそれに比べたら他の本能はどう
生きるかやろだから生きる力があればどう
生きるかもできてくるんだけどだからまず
生命力を高める生命力を高める方法として
は生きるか死ぬかの状態に追い込む必ず
生きようとするから人間だからねそれを
繰り返してるうちに生命力が高まってくん
やだけどこれも本能だから本能が伸びとる
間にやっとかんととそこで生きる力の最大
値が決まるから生きる力の最大値を今度は
理性で出すことはできるうちに来た子供
たち本当にこう生きる力のないのが多かっ
たよ辛いことするぐらいなら死んだ方が
ええとポッと思っちゃうんやな生命力を
理性で引き出すやり方っていうのが死の
危険に直面するっていうことですかそれは
本のが生きようとするからからここで
ひっくり返った船にに捕まれはしらんやろ
だからつまろとするこれが理性
ね大人からの質問で不快感で人は進歩
するっていうところはこ皆さん納得され
てるんですよ今それやろうとするとま
いじめだとかパワだとかって言われて
なかなか外から不快感与えられることって
ないと思うんですようんそういう時にこう
不快感で進歩するってい方法を使いたい人
はどうすればいいんですかね上司に怒って
もらえばええじゃんパワもらえばええやん
上司からしてもパオハって言われたくな
いっていうのがだからリベラルはいかんね
潰すんよ日本をねパハラしてもらえない人
はどうすればいいですかねこれ自分で
コンプレックスに陥って俺はダメだ俺は
ダメだという風にずっと思い込んででそれ
からダメではダメだにしてなんとかしよう
とするそと怒りが湧いてくるわね意思は
しっかりしとれば正しいことをするだから
怒りと意思これが大事なから本な意思を
強めるにはどうしたらええかを考えにゃ
ね好調的にはパワハっていう言葉自体が
あんまりよろしくないっていう感じなん
ですかまず力やね力というのは善なんよ
ただし力はね群れのためにあるわけもし
その力を自分のために使ったらこれ悪に
なり得るしなりやすいんやだから群れの
ために力を使うのは全パワハていうのは
その群れの中のダメなやつのために力使っ
とるわけやろそいつを開くというような
精神論は悪くリベラルは悪く自分のために
するパワハラとかは良くない使い方って
いうことですかそうそう大義士なんかが
自分が儲かるような法律を作っちまったり
ね高速道路の路線を決める時に自分の土地
の上ルを通るように高速道路を作らしたり
で儲けようというこれは力を自分のために
使ったわけよねみんなが1番いいように
もし作ったらそれは全だどうしても日本は
な悪が大なっちゃうわね部下に八つ当たり
するパワハラとかは悪だけど会社のために
やってるのは全叱り方は難しいやろから
相手が納得する叱り方をせないけから相手
が本当に悪いとこを叱ってやるとね相手
納得するんよこれは俺のために叱って
くれるなと思うわ実際に叱られたらそれが
分かる恐怖でしるのがおるやろ部下が怖い
んよね下手すると俺より先にしちまうとか
ね俺より仕事ができるとかそういうやつを
叱ることがある相手がおる限り恐怖が続く
んやないかだから相手を追っ払うか殺し
ちまうかそういうことをせんと恐怖はさら
んのやね再現のない叱り方になってくる
やろうちのあれでも弱いやつが叱るのは
禁止ない弱いやつは生徒が怖い生徒が怖い
からむちゃくちゃな叱り方になっちまう
自分の方が上やコチだからそいつを利用し
たり
俺の名前使ってしったりね虎の家を狩ると
いうそんなものはだめだすぐばれるしね
えっとね私の言うことは正しいこと
ばっかりだだから今からまだ続くから
え正しい
人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それを送り
たけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ
JA